- Your husband, Wyatt
is this son of Goldie
Hawn and Kurt Russell?
I remember whenever I was,
I actually was friends with Reba before,
but I ended up being related
to her because of it,
But it was so funny.
It was interesting
'cause I was friends first,
but isn't that weird to like grow up
with someone that you've seen
and then all of a sudden you're like,
they're your in-laws?
Isn't that weird?
- Yeah, it is kind of weird.
I think the reason, you know, it's funny,
'cause I just loved him so much
that there was something
in my brain that was like,
I just want my in-laws to like me
and then I would just kind of
- Absolutely.
- occasionally remember like,
oh, that's this person
who I've seen through it.
Like they're just the most normal,
I mean,
- That's cool.
- people say that about, you know,
but it's just like you kind
of forget pretty quickly.
- Absolutely.
- Sometimes it hits me they're,
they're the best, they really are.
- No, it is always funny though.
I was lucky.
I felt like that would have been
when I found this out about
you I was like, oh, if I would,
if that would have happened opposite,
like I was friends with Reba first
and then that happened.
- Right, yeah.
- If that had been opposite
I'd have been terrified.
I would have wanted to
say the wrong thing ever.
I would have been like just scared, but--
- No I don't.
Yeah, they are so welcoming
that I was, I definitely came into it.
I think, I think the first
time my parents met them,
I'm from the South, I'm from Texas too,
so I've protected like that, my mom had--
- This is why I love you, okay.
- Okay, my mom had like a
rhinestone shirt that said
Hollywood on it and she'll kill me saying,
she'll kill me for saying this, oh no!
But I was like,
I was nervous at first
and then it went away within five seconds
and now we've been together
five and a half years
and they're just the greatest.
- Yeah, no, it wears off.
Yeah it definitely, or not wears off.
It just wears in.
- Yeah.
- It becomes normal.